eccentric the heart soul of this very  Beach green Johnson in zac efron fight  crime and bring the laughs in Baywatch I  chose my training oh ma you see a to his  old enemies and new adventures for Jack  Sparrow in pirates of the caribbean dead  men tell no tales  a crew exploring a distant planet makes  an unimaginable and terrifying discovery  in Alien compass where is it see what's  hot in theaters with this week's  anticipation  so what's your weekend to get going to  be download the Fandango app for all the  latest Showtime  tickets and trailers get a movie ticket  to see Disney's Pirates of the Caribbean  dead men tell no tales  we need buy a $25 limited edition Red  Robin gift card hey Ravi angel